monsieur le président cher nicolas amis
militants et cadres du mouvement et luz
et parlementaires oui ce conseil
national c'est notre parlement c'est
notre maison c'est le lieu d'expression
privilégié des militants c'est vous
c'est vous effectivement militants de
terrain militant des idées qui fait
notre force et qui assure et notre
solidité c'est vous qui assurer la
pérennité de notre famille politique
ensemble
ensemble nous avons tous traversés nous
avons traversé ces soirées de joie de
liesse pour ton élection
nicolas et pour bien d'être aux
élections de ceux qui sont ici
nous avons également connu des soirées
de tristesse nous avons surmonté des
tensions des crises nous avons connu des
moments d'exaltation et aussi des
moments de doute et quand certains de
nos adversaires
quand certains médias parfois à nos
alliés
parfois aussi certains de nos
responsables doutent et parlait parfois
de notre disparition c'est vous militant
qui avait maintenu le flambeau de nos
convictions
le socle de nos valeurs notre ambition
commune pour une certaine idée de la
politique et pour une certaine idée de
la france
et aujourd'hui est aujourd'hui plus que
jamais dans la perspective de la
préparation des grandes échéances de
nous allons encore une fois avoir besoin
de vous depuis son élection nicolas à la
tête de notre parti nous avons renouvelé
quasiment toutes nos instances et
aujourd'hui c'est la dernière étape de
ce renouvellement avec chacune et chacun
d'entre vous je veux remercier très
chaleureusement jean pierre raffarin qui
a veillé pendant toutes ces années à ce
que chacun se sente bien dans nos débats
avec son humour qui désamorcer les
tensions avec son autorité sereine qui
affirme ses convictions
merci à toi jean pierre
alors chers amis aujourd'hui je suis
candidate à la présidence de notre
conseil national je suis candidate parce
que je veux que ce conseil national soit
le coeur battant de notre mouvement
le lieu où s'exprime vraiment la voix
des militants
je les dis à tous ceux que j'ai pu
constater au cours de ces derniers jours
bien loin qu effectivement des tableaux
des plateaux de télévision parce que je
préfère le contact personnel avec vous
vous le savez depuis longtemps je
voulais dit à mes yeux c'est vous qui
devez avoir la parole parce que vous
avez mieux que personne que dans cette
période où de nombreux de nos
compatriotes doute des politiques
estiment qu'il y à un fossé entre ce que
les responsables politiques disent et ce
qu'ils vivent sur le terrain eh bien ce
sont les militants qui ont ce rôle
essentiel de contacts privilégiés et 3
vrai avec les réelles préoccupations du
terrain et à travers vous c'est donc eux
qui doivent avoir la parole
prioritairement ici bon nous sommes
entre nous on peut se dire c'est vrai
que des successions de discours
certainement très intéressants mais
souvent toujours des mêmes finissent par
un peu nous lasser et que nous voudrions
les uns et les autres à voir peut-être
davantage de place de temps pour nous
exprimer
c'est vrai nicolas que tu à améliorer
les choses
en permettant qu'il y ait des dialogues
et des tables rondes mais je crois qu'il
faut aller beaucoup plus loin
ce que je veux pour notre conseil
national c'est que la moitié de la durée
de chaque conseil national soit
consacrée à des sujets que vous aurez
vous cadre de mouvements et
parlementaires de terrain déterminé
comme étant les sujets prioritaires des
français et que sur ces sujets ce soit
vous les militants qui pariaient
et vous savez que c'est possible
lorsque je présidais notre part famille
politique ou une partie de notre famille
politique j'ai toujours veillé à
l'expression de chacun au coeur de nos
débats sur le terrain dans des
commissions et autres
vous savez que je les fais et que vous
ne répondiez pas simplement par oui ou
non mais en apportant effectivement vos
idées et d'ailleurs jean-françois tout
doit s'en souvenir puisque c'est toi qui
préparaient des conventions et bien ce
qui a permis notre succès d'hier avec
vous je le ferai demain car c'est vous
qui devez avoir la parole avec la même
volonté d'écouté de prendre en
permanence le pouls de nos territoires
je souhaite que notre conseil national
est désormais aussi des sessions
décentralisée dans les grandes régions
du nord du sud de l'est ou de l'ouest
je souhaite que deux fois par an nous
ayons la possibilité de nous retrouver
sur les grandes thématiques de ces
grandes régions de façon à ce que
s'exprime d'abord ceux qui sont sur le
terrain et que nous puissions ainsi
montrer à nos concitoyens à travers la
presse quotidienne régionale
ce que nous faisons pour les écouter et
pour répondre à leurs attentes comme le
prévoient nos statuts j'imagine un
conseil national qui soit un laboratoire
d'idées il doit fonctionner comme un
parlement et je veux aussi créer des
commissions
nous avons les nouveaux moyens de
communication qui nous permettent de le
faire sans nous réunir et bien je veux
que ce soit ça aussi et je veux que
chacun s'exprime librement
il faut je termine là dessus
effectivement il faut que chacun se
sente bien
je suis gaulliste je suis de sensibilité
gaullienne comme l'a très bien dit henri
guaino hier je veux que mes idées soient
reconnus comme je veux que les i
de nos amis centristes libéraux ou
radicaux soient reconnus je veux
garantir la neutralité de notre conseil
national
comme je les ai toujours fait avec une
autre dépendance d'esprit que certains
appelleront du mauvais caractère mais
c'est comme ça que nous avancerons
est ce que je veux c'est qu'on sent
derrière le candidat qui aura été
retenue dans les primaires
eh bien nous offrions aux français de
nouvelles perspectives que nous
construisions ensemble un avenir digne
de notre histoire à notre pays que nous
aimons tant la france